darf mein arbeitgeber mir vorschreiben
dass sie ein corinna test machen muss
also grundsätzlichen nein
das vorstellbar dass corona textes ist
ein ziemlicher eingriff ein gewinn ist
allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht einfach
so ein test an zuordnung ist nach
unserer meinung nicht möglich allerdings
anders sein wenn tatsächlich symptome
vorliegen ob man bereits allein die
tatsache heranziehen kann dass man in
einem risikogebiet da ist jetzt bei
meiner meinung nach nicht der fall weil
mallorca insofern nicht als risikogebiet
ausgewiesen ist unserer meinung nach
geht es grundsätzlich nicht wie gehabt
bei vorliegt photoshop
jetzt haben sie gerade selber gesagt
mallorca ist momentan kein risikogebiet
wie sieht es denn aus darf mein
arbeitgeber mir trotzdem sagen er möchte
nicht dass ich nach mallorca fliegen
oder an andere orte jetzt im
sommerurlaub weil die gefahr besteht
dass ich mich vielleicht anstecke also
das gilt noch weitere 1 ist das
persönlichkeitsrecht wo ich meine urlaub
verbringen möchte ist meine privatsache
allerdings kann er sicherlich anmerken
ob es sinnvoll ist in ein solches gebiet
zu reisen weil möglicherweise die frage
steht dass ich gar nicht mehr
zurückkommen und dann vielleicht meine
arbeit nicht mehr antreten kann
das risiko bleibt beim arbeitnehmer
natürlich weiterhin er muss sorge dazu
tragen rechtzeitig wieder am
arbeitsplatz sein zu können
und das kann natürlich gefährlich sein
wo man reist wo es schwierig ist wie
zurückzukommen
dem arbeitgeber geht es natürlich auch
darum andere arbeitnehmer beispielsweise
im büro dann zu schützen
wie sieht es also mit quarantäne aus
dafür zumindest verlangen dass ich nach
dem urlaub zwei wochen von zu hause
arbeiten um wenigstens die anderen zu
schützen
das ist schwierig weil wenn er mit dem
arbeitnehmer keine vereinbarung darüber
hat im home office arbeiten zu dürfen
dann ist es keine möglichkeit ihn
einfach nach hause zu schicken
einvernehmlich geht das natürlich wenn
der arbeitnehmer ein sich die kisten
sagt okay gut von zu hause arbeiten ist
mit einer option ist es möglich aber
auch hier wieder ein eingriff in das
allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht der
arbeitgeber kann nicht bestimmen dass
ich von zu hause aus arbeiten
und deswegen ist es so einfach nicht
wenn er mich nach hause geschickt und
mir sagt ich soll nicht zur arbeit
kommen bei der die befürchtung hat dass
ich vielleicht krank bin dann wird aber
unter umständen nicht trotz beide
bezahlen müssen auch wenn ich keine
arbeitsleistung von zu hause aus
erbringen kann